well criticism is growing here in
germany and across europe over moscow's
decision to shut down the russian
operations of this channel deutsche
welle the move is apparently in
retaliation for german media regulators
prohibiting russia's state media outlet
rt from broadcasting here in germany now
critics say rt often broadcasts kremlin
propaganda and disinformation
deutsche weller's moscow office is now
closed and dw's journalists can no
longer work from russia
the russian government announced on
thursday that it would shut down dw's
bureau and revoke the accreditation of
dw's journalists in russia it also said
in a statement it would terminate the
satellite and other broadcasting output
of deutsche welle in the country
the measures come after germany's media
regulator banned the german language
broadcasting of russia's state media rt
which began operating in december 2021
under a serbian license regulators say
the license does not align with european
law rt has also been accused of
spreading propaganda and disinformation
the fact that deutsche weller has been
deprived of its broadcasting license and
that its employees have also been denied
accreditation is completely unacceptable
that one is is fulcrum inacceptable this
violates the freedom of the press
and independent media is after all a
sign of free and democratic states
that says a lot
deutsche has our full solidarity
the german government says russia's
actions are unjustified and called it a
hostile decision yes
these drastic measures from the russian
side are not acceptable by any means
it is a truly aggressive act
but we don't need aggressive acts
we need dialogue we need de-escalation
and not escalation
escalators
the russian government also said it
plans to initiate proceedings to label
deutsche welle as a media outlet acting
as a foreign agent
a designation that carries further
government scrutiny
for now dw is considering possible legal
avenues and says it will not stop
reporting on russia
my colleague jared reed has more on this
story
i'm here with the director general of dw
peter lindberg mr limburg welcome what
update can you give us
in respect to the closure of dw's bureau
in moscow
well the office is closed and the
colleagues over there stopped working
they gathered this morning there to take
their personal things out
and gave back the accreditations during
the day and as far as we've learned the
two non-national
russian nationals
must not leave the country immediately
but we are not
quite sure whether this has to be done
in the next day so we we we're still
waiting for for a real um confirmation
that they can stay how are the
colleagues going are they in any kind of
danger at all i don't see an immediate
danger and i but i see that they are
shocked and that are disappointed on the
other hand they're professional
journalists and they will cope with this
situation
and now we have to wait uh how we can
support them at the best
you mentioned just a little bit earlier
but what
concretely if you know will happen to
both the
russian local staff and the non-russian
staff of the bureau in moscow
well first of all they can't work for
the moment and we are in close contact
with them and we will support them
wherever we can and what exactly will
happen we'll have to see and wait what
steps is deutsche bella planning to
undertake now in terms of appealing to
the russian government to to reverse its
decision
well we asked our lawyer in moscow to
protest against these measures and
maybe also go to court
if possible but we we have to wait also
uh what she will tell us when she comes
back from the russian authorities
is any kind of political pressure from
the german government uh expected for
them to step in and and do something
i think the german government has
already protested against these measures
and
i'm sure that this will be also on the
political agenda for everybody who talks
with the russian government
and up till now i can't complain that
the solidarity also from the german
government and other parties is there
it's very good there's been also a lot
of solidarity from uh deutsche welle's
media partners media competitors to
other institutions how encouraged have
you been by that
oh it's very encouraging to see that
there is so much solidarity for deutsche
welle around the globe and also the bbc
or france medium on the european
broadcasting unions and others they send
messages of solidarity and i think it's
really important not also for us working
here in berlin or in bonn but it's
important for our colleagues who are
working in moscow that there are people
who really support them and who are
supporting free press
peter lindbergh thank you
well later this month german chancellor
olaf schultz is due to visit ukraine and
russia where he will discuss tensions
over ukraine
schultz has described the build-up of
russian troops on ukraine's border as
very serious
and said any invasion would have
consequences next week's visit will be
the first face-to-face meeting between
russian president vladimir putin and
chancellor schultz since he
took over from former chancellor angela
merkel last december